RICHARD FULCHER:
Good afternoon.
Thanks for coming to our talk
to on Android and designing
for application structure.
I'm Rich Fulcher.
I'm one of the UI leads on
the Android design team.
JENS NAGEL: And I'm
Jens Nagel.
I'm an interaction designer
on the Android team.
RICHARD FULCHER: So let's
just jump right in.
So what do we mean when we
talk about structure?
Maybe the first vision that
jumps into your head is the
idea of an architectural
floor plan.
Here, structure is what the
physical components that go
into defining what spaces are
present and also provide the
support for any of the
activities you might want to
do in those space.
But structure doesn't
have to be as
immediately visible as that.
Our bones provide structure
for our body.
They provide valuable attachment
points for the
functions of muscles
and organs--
good stuff like that.
Our applications are similar
to both of these examples.
We need to define the spaces,
and we need to provide ways to
attach functionality in
just the right places.
So the kind of particular
thoughtful presentation, that
is what goes into the
application structure.
A well-structured app has
at least three things.
First, it's easy
and efficient.
If it were a house, the doorways
would be the right
width, so you could
go through them.
The floors would be solid.
There'd be ample light to do
all the things you need
to do within it.
It takes advantage
of proximity.
So the kitchen and the dining
room are connected together,
and they're not separated
by the garage.
And then finally, it has
navigational consistency.
Maybe all of the front rooms
are connected together, but
the back rooms all adjoin
a common hallway.
So our talk is going to focus on
how do you find these same
types of natural structures
for your application.
And for those purposes,
we're going to
start with an example.
So let's say that we're going
to design an application to
find a place to get
a drink nearby.
And with this many developers in
the room, this should be up
on the Play Store by
tomorrow night.
So you've probably heard the
oft-repeated precept that form
follows function.
So it makes sense to first
ask, what does my app do?
And by answering that, you'll
get a better sense of the
structure that is needed to
support all that activity.
So is the answer to that the
30-second stream of buzzwords
you spew at the friend of the
friend who might be a venture
capitalist?
No.
That's too high-level.
That's probably incomprehensible
as well.
Likewise, it's not the list of
every feature, every last
function that the application
is going to perform.
That's too low-level.
It's too separated from
the actual user goals.
Like Goldilocks, we need
something that's just right,
just in the middle
of those two.
And fortunately, there are
modeling techniques that we
can use that give us that.
One of them is use cases.
And a use case is just a
sequence of interaction
between a system or between
an actor in a system--
the actor being the users for
us, the system being the
application--
that achieves a specific task
or completes a goal.
When you write out a use case as
a narrative description, it
might look something
like this.
So for BarKeeper, we have a
use case that we need to
support, which is
finding a bar.
We might identify who the main
actor in this use case is,
what kind of things have
to happen before we
can get into it.
But then the core of the use
case here is just a dialogue,
really, between the actor
and the system.
The drinker does this, the
BarKeeper app does this, back
and forth, back and forth.
Now, you can add a lot of
extensions to this.
You can think about variations
of this task.
You can find a nearby bar.
You could think about other
post conditions
for success or failure.
I like to keep these
just really simple.
The value here is in the
content, not the format.
And you want to make it
something that anybody on the
team can offer.
There's something in use case
modeling that's oft overlooked
that is actually really helpful
for application
structure, and that's creating
use case diagrams.
Now, these are really
simple diagrams.
They just have three
components to them.
The first is an actor.
The stick figure is the official
parlance that they
use to communicate that.
There's the use cases,
just the title of
the use cases circled.
And then finally, there are
relationships, arrows that
connect actors to use cases and
that connect use cases to
each other to form extensions.
If you take a bunch of these and
put them together, you get
a diagram like this for our
BarKeeper application.
There's a lot of content encoded
into this, but it's
still just arrows, circles,
stick figures, a
little bit of text.
Use case diagrams are
intentionally
very easy to draw.
They're not one of these fancy
pants deliverables that gives
a designer a leg up over
the rest of the team.
Everybody can make
these drawings.
And they don't have to be
captured digitally.
You can just draw it on paper,
on a white board.
You can use stickies.
That's usually where I start.
So the use case diagram is just
a very quick overview
that anyone can decipher that
gives the overall description
of what your app is
going to perform.
Now, I took a big leap
to get to that point.
So let me back up and walk
through some of the steps that
were used to create
the diagram.
The first is you have to take
stock of everything you want
your application to do.
And you want to capture all the
actors, all the different
roles that they could perform
within your system.
And likewise, you want to
enumerate all of the use cases
that are going to be there.
Just write them all out.
You don't have to do the
narrative descriptions now.
In fact, you might not
ever have to do them.
Just capture everything you
want this app to do in the
user's terms.
The second step is to
prioritize them.
And this can be very,
very coarse--
three categories.
And it's especially important
to prioritize the use cases.
Which ones are really
important?
Which ones are less so?
Start to give a focus to what
your app is trying to do most
often or most importantly.
The third thing is to get into
sequencing, both how do the
individual actors connect to
these cases, which are the
ones that they want direct
access to, versus the use
cases that are just natural
extensions of other use cases.
I can't go directly to
View Bar Details.
I've got to locate
a bar first.
And then the last step
is decomposition.
If you have a use case that
feels broad or vague or covers
a lot of ground, you
can split it apart.
Break it into smaller pieces
to attack it more
specifically.
And this can be helpful, because
those smaller pieces
might get reused by components
elsewhere in your system or
might be kind of specific,
have relationships
with other use cases.
You put them all back together,
and you've got the
same diagram that
we started with.
Now, this is roughly the
official UML format for a use
case diagram--
Unified Modeling Language.
We can go a little bit further
just by putting a little bit
of priority into some
of the strokes.
We got that sense of priority
during the analysis, so let's
layer it into the diagram.
Take the most important or most
frequently accessed use
cases and relationships
and make them bold.
Take the ones that are low
priority, low frequency, and
have them recede a little bit
by just dashing them out.
Same diagram, but a little
bit more content to it.
And we already start to see some
of the key paths through
our application that
we know our app
structure needs to support.
A drinker needs to find a bar.
They probably need one
nearby right now.
They want to get to the bar
details and find out where to
get there and make
sure it's open.
So we've used this
use case diagram.
It's starting to tell us about
our app structure.
But what in particular can it
tell us about the hierarchy?
Or how can it help us describe
what we're doing?
Well, it can tell us when we
have a broad hierarchy.
If we have an actor who's
connected to a number of use
cases directly, all of equal
priority, then those are all
reasonable starting places for
the user, and we want to make
it easy for them to get
from one starting
point to the other.
On the other hand, if we have
more focus in our use case, if
we see that there's one use case
in particular that's more
important than the others, then
maybe we can have those
less important ones be a
little less directly
accessible.
We can make different structural
choices in how we
present our app between
those two.
And likewise, we might have
this condition of
statefulness, where different
users have different
priorities between
the use cases.
An example of this is the
Phone app on Android.
When you open it up, it's
in one of three states.
It's in either the Dialer
or the Call Log or
the Favorites view.
And those correspond
to different
types of user behaviors.
There are still people that
just dial numbers.
There are people that rely
entirely on the Call Log.
And we want that app to open
into those conditions for
those different types of users,
the different actors or
user roles.
It can reveal depth.
And depth is particularly
important when you have these
deep chains of use cases that
are truly separate, that fan
out from each other without
interconnections.
In that case, if you have one
section where the user would
quickly want to navigate to a
different section, your app's
structure needs to
account for that.
And finally, there's the sense
of interconnectedness, where
use cases come together from
multiple threads, where there
are these hubs.
You know these are really
important features that you
need to work on.
These are probably some of
the hero moments of your
application, because many users
gravitate to it at some
point during the use
of your app.
So there's one last trick you
can do when it comes to taking
use case diagram in starting to
think about app hierarchy.
If you take the use case diagram
and you just rotate it
by 90 degrees, and if you think
about each of these use
cases as a screen in your
application, you have a first
approximation of what your app
hierarchy would look like.
Now, this isn't perfect.
There are occasions where the
one screen to one use case
mapping isn't going
to be ideal.
It's a good rule of thumb for
phones, but sometimes you'll
bump into a use case that just
has more complexity to it, so
it needs to devolve across
a couple of screens.
Or you might have a cluster of
use cases that are fairly
simple and can actually
be addressed all
within a single screen.
But this is a good starting
point for thinking about your
app hierarchy.
So let me turn to Jens now, and
we'll talk a little bit
about what some of the common
patterns for introducing
hierarchy are.
JENS NAGEL: Thanks, Rich.
So of course, apps come in
all shapes and sizes.
There's a huge variety in
purpose and complexity.
But if you wanted to build a
blueprint, if you took all
apps and tried to build a common
blueprint, it would
probably look something
like this, where
you have a top level.
And the top level is,
of course, the
entryway into your app.
It can be one screen.
It can be multiple screens.
That really depends on what your
core use cases are and
how many of them you have.
But the important thing is that
the user really finds
their main use case is covered
here, and it's guided down the
structure in order
to complete them.
The top level is really about
displaying functional breadth
and establishing an identity
for your app.
So as you can see from this
example, just by taking a
quick glance at them, you can
really understand what this
app is about.
Then next up is category
browsing.
This is where you drill deeper
into your hierarchy or into
your functionality.
It's the connective tissue that
connects the top level
and the bottom level.
The category browsing
is really typical to
organizational hierarchies, such
as albums, for example,
or folders.
And then the last level
is the detail level.
And that is, of course, where
you complete a task, where you
consume data, or where
you write an email.
And of course, the screens are
very much depending on the
data type that you're
dealing with here.
But out of all of those three
levels, the top level is
really the most important
one in terms of
your structural decisions.
Your choices here really dictate
how well users will
find their core use cases
covered and can satisfy them
going forward.
The top level is really about
communication with your user,
if you think about it.
It's sort of your quick elevator
speech of what the
purpose is.
Like in this example, the data
of the screen quickly shows
you, well, this is really
about telephony.
I'm all about making
phone calls.
But besides the purpose, it also
introduces the breadth of
functionality, sort of
how wide your app is,
what else can I do.
And here the other facets, for
example, in the calling app
are Call History.
And there's also
the Phonebook.
And I can immediately
see that.
So this kind of information
should disclose itself as
quickly as possible, so the
communication here really
needs to be succinct and to the
point, because with all
those apps out there in the Play
Store, people might give
up on you quickly.
If they don't see that, oh, I
can't really do with this app
what I set out to do, they grab
a different one that does
a better job of communicating.
So always be mindful that you're
actually entering into
a dialogue with the user on
the top level screen.
So allowing the user to
explore the top level
functionality is crucial to
making sure that all your use
cases are covered, like
here, for example, in
the current I/O app.
Android supports different
established patterns to just
do that-- to communicate what
you can do inside of an app
and to switch between the
different facets of your app.
Let's take a quick look at
what those patterns are.
First up is the six-pack.
We call it informally
the six-pack.
It's essentially a menu screen
that is the sole screen at the
top of your hierarchy.
And structurally, people have
to navigate through the menu
screen in order to get to the
deeper levels where they can
then work on their task.
So they always have to
traverse the screen.
This can, of course, mean that
if you want to explore
multiple facets or if you're not
quite sure where to go in
order to [? met ?] your use
case, you can imagine that
there might be a lot of yo-yoing
up and down could
happen here, if I go to
[INAUDIBLE], down, up through
the six-pack, down to the
flies, and so forth.
So it's really a feasible way
of solving the top level
navigation problem.
It's sort of straightforward and
simple, and everything is
focused on that one simple
choice of where to go next.
And all the navigation choices
really disclose themselves
immediately.
But if you look at it, it's not
overly interesting to look
at, because after a while,
people learn the
structure of your app.
And then they come
for the data.
And there's no data
to be seen here.
So you always have this speed
bump before you actually get
to the interesting stuff.
Also, this is not accessible
from lower level.
So as soon as you navigate
away, you always have to
navigate up in order to
switch to a different
facet of your app.
Next up is fixed tabs.
And fixed tabs is really a
common pattern on Android.
You can see that now we have
three screens in the top level
side by side.
And they're random access, so
I can press on any tab in
order to navigate
there quickly.
It's really fast
and efficient.
Since the tabs are a bit out of
the way, you should always
make sure that you support
side swiping to navigate
between the top levels
quickly.
But in summary, what's good
about fixed tabs is that
they're really highly
explorable.
You see all the choices of the
top level exposed in the tab.
And it's ruthlessly efficient.
So at any time, you can
jump back and forth.
So in instances where you write
an app where you foresee
people having to switch often
between your top level facets,
this is really a good
control to use.
Not so good is it's limited to
three items, because it takes
up a horizontal space to
put items in there.
It also takes up vertical real
estate, as you can see here.
So if space is precious in your
data segment below, then
be mindful that you're giving
away space by using the tab
control up there.
And again, it's also
not accessible
from the lower levels.
So as soon as you navigate away,
you have to navigate up
to get back to the top
level navigation.
RICHARD FULCHER: So Spinners are
a common alternative when
you have more actions than can
fit comfortably into a tab.
And so the Spinner
fits properly
within the Action Bar.
You touch upon it, and a menu
opens to give you all the
destinations.
So it can cover more than just
the two or three that would
fit in a tab.
It has some downsides as well.
On the positive side,
it's compact.
You get a lot of options.
On the negative side, those top
level options still need
to be navigated back up to.
So I still need to return to
whatever level I'm presenting
that Spinner at in order to
change and move to the
different category.
It's a little less efficient
than a tab.
It's a touch and then
a subsequent
touch to make the selection.
It's a little less direct
in that sense.
And importantly, you're not
revealing as much of the app
structure when the Spinner
is collapsed.
In an example like this where
it's types of vehicle that I
might be shopping for, the
user has a good way of
thinking about that set.
They have an expectation of,
well, if it says sedans, maybe
there are other things here that
are minivans and hybrids
and things like that.
That can be less true when the
functions are more disparate.
If this category was called
favorites, do I assume that
all is also available there?
It can be a little unclear
for the user.
So six-packs, tabs, Spinners
have all been in Android for
quite awhile.
And we have a new pattern
that's been introduced
recently that we need to talk
about, and that's the
Navigation Drawer.
JENS NAGEL: And the Navigation
Drawer--
you might say well, I've seen
that in a couple of Android
apps already.
It's really been a
community-driven pattern so far.
But we now took the Navigation
Drawer and formalized its use
as part of the Android
Design Guide.
So if you're interested in using
this pattern after the
talk, head on over to the Style
Guide and take a look.
There's also sample code
available and a good developer
section to it.
So what is the Navigation
Drawer?
Essentially, the Navigation
Drawer is a menu panel of your
app's most important screens.
So it slides on top of your
content when you either tap on
the application icon at the top
while it's decorated with
the Navigation Drawer icon, or
you can also do what we call
an edge swipe.
From the very edge of the
screen, you can pull in the
Navigation Drawer
from the left.
The Navigation Drawer really
contains your, what we call,
navigation hub-- so places that
users will likely visit
frequently.
Top level of use are always
navigation hubs.
So you should always
include those.
But now since the Navigation
Drawer is really a
transitional element,
you can now also
include lower level screens.
So if you have particularly deep
apps, now you can take
advantage of the fact that you
can bring up this menu from
anywhere and provide links
to deeper level
structures as well.
So all screens that are
represented in the Navigation
Drawer should actually be
decorated with the Navigation
Drawer icon next to the
application icon.
And that gives the signal I can
expand in here by tapping
on the application icon.
All other lower level screens
that are not represented in
the Navigation Drawer retain the
classic up behavior that
we've had in Android
for a while now.
The good thing about Navigation
Drawer is also that
it gives you a little bit more
space to organize your
content, because it can also
hold more content.
So there might be a need for you
to do something like this.
So you can add icons,
for example.
You can segment your menu
using dividers.
You can also add things
such as counters.
So for example, if the
corresponding screen has new
updates, you could say, well,
you have three new messages in
this particular screen
if you go there.
Additionally, you can also
show collapsible items to
organize lower level content
grouping, such as on the
right, and allow the users to
hide them, which can come in
handy if you have a lot of items
where a good range of
them are subordinate to other
items in the Drawer.
So in conclusion, what's good
about the Navigation Drawer,
of course, is it can display
many views, probably more
views than any other top level
switching mechanism that we
talked about.
It's also compact
when collapsed.
So there's really not much UI
to it while its collapsed.
Once in a while, you'll see the
little Navigation Drawer
icon in the Action Bar.
It can include lower level
screens, which is nice because
now you can, if you have deep
apps, circumvent a lot of the
navigation work to drill
into deeper levels.
And it's, of course, accessible
from anywhere.
Slight downside is, of course,
it's usually collapsed.
So you have to open
it in order to see
what's actually in it.
So after we've discussed all
the different top level
switching mechanisms, we want
to see where those patterns
actually work best.
And to do that, we want to
play a little game of
What If with you.
So what if some of our Google
Apps use different switching
patterns and see if that
would work or not.
And first up is Rich
with the Calendar.
RICHARD FULCHER: So Calendar,
the app that many of you know
and some of you love, some of
you hate, currently uses the
Spinner as its top level
switching pattern--
perfectly suitable
choice here.
And the user has a very clear
understanding of the
relationship between days
and weeks and months.
So it's natural to expect those
other options that would
be in the Spinner.
It's very compact.
Sits up at the top neatly.
Titles the screen very nicely.
It's a good choice.
We could have the Calendar use
the Navigation Drawer.
That would also be viable.
It's similar in a lot of
ways to the Spinner.
It still has statefulness.
It still provides a specific
title to the display.
I guess the one thing I'd
caution against here is it
makes the Drawer feel a little
under-populated.
It has those four options
within it.
It's not likely to expand
to include more
options in the future.
There's a [INAUDIBLE]
coming, but not much
more than that.
And on a tablet or a larger
form factor, that's a fair
amount of empty space that
you're creating, just to bring
in this panel.
But it would work.
Tabs would be a poor choice
for a few reasons.
One is that most Calendar users
fall into one camp or
the other, kind of like our
Phone dialers before.
You've got the people that are
very busy Calendar users, who
live in the Day View.
You've got other Calendar
users who have much more
sparsely populated calendars,
and they live in the week or
the month view.
The tabs are a great tool
for when you're changing
frequently.
But that's not how most
people use a Calendar.
And the downsides go
a little further.
By putting the tabs up there,
you're doubling the amount of
space that you're taking up for
the top level UI structure
above the user's actual data.
You're reducing the amount of
content the user can see about
their Calendar.
And then, very importantly,
you introduce this very
unfavorable interaction
with the gestures.
The user might expect,
oh, I can swipe from
day to day to day.
And that's a really natural
thing to be able to do.
But once tabs are in place, you
have this conflict between
oh, am I my swiping
from day to week?
Or am I swiping from
day to day?
And you have to make a
resolution for that, which may
be unexpected to the user given
the context that you're
bringing to it.
And then the six-pack or the
dashboard is similarly not
well-suited.
And you can put all of those
categories at the top, but
again, most users pick one
and stick with it.
They don't have to switch, and
they certainly don't want to
be asked to switch every time
they enter the application.
Jens mentioned the speed
bump before.
That's what this feels
like when you use it.
It also just pushes the user's
data down lower.
I'm not seeing any of
my appointments when
I first come in.
And there are ways you could
jerry-rig that in and just put
the first few appointments
there.
But usually, that's but
not enough context.
That's the kind of thing that
a widget on your home screen
is great for, or
a notification.
But the app should get to more
of the content more rapidly.
JENS NAGEL: Next up is Clock,
a relatively recent
application for Android.
So Clock uses tabs and
efficiently communicates the
other facets of the app.
So it gives you the heads up
that it's really more than the
simple Clock going on here,
because it highlights that
there is a timer, and there's
also a stopwatch.
So it does a good job
at communicating.
Since the data communicates the
purpose of the app nicely,
we really don't need a
traditional action bar that
tells us the name of the app.
As soon as you open it, you
know this is a Clock.
Instead, the Center View, the
Clock View, actually uses a
split action bar and displays
pertinent actions for that
particular screen at the bottom,
which also nicely
visually balances
out that screen.
Vertical space is not a problem,
so using the split
action bar is actually great.
Below the top level, as a small
detail here, we talked
about the split action bar, and
that gives you access to
two screens.
One of them is the City
Select, and that is a
configuration screen to let you
turn the Clock screen into
your personal world clock by
selecting different cities
around the world.
So that is really a
customization of that
particular screen.
So therefore, being subordinate
to the Clock
screen makes a lot of sense.
Next to it, though, we have
the Alarm screen.
And that really feels more
like a place of passage.
You could really imagine pulling
that into the top
level here as well if we
wouldn't be going past the
threshold of the items
that we would like to
see in the tab control.
So let's keep that in
mind when we look
at the other options.
So for example, if Clock
used Spinner, it
would be totally fine.
Some of the options
wouldn't disclose
themselves as readily.
But we could pull in alarms as
the fourth item into the top
level here as well.
Switching between the facet
takes a little bit more work.
And now we're introducing text
labels inside of the action
bar at the top.
And that detracts a little bit
further from the aesthetic
simplicity of the
original design.
The Navigation Drawer is a very
similar story to Spinner
You can, again, pull in alarms,
but you, again, have
more navigational effort.
The new options that you have
around Timer and Stopwatch
don't disclose themselves,
necessarily, until you open
the Drawer.
So in hindsight, if you put all
three of them aside, all
navigation mechanisms are
sound and work OK.
But the visual balance and
simplicity achieved by the
tabs is really what makes
this a winner.
RICHARD FULCHER: Bachelor number
three is the Gallery.
Gallery uses a Spinner right
now, although it uses it in a
slightly different way
than Calendar does.
It's more of choosing which way
you want to view the same
set of data.
It's going to be a set of
photos collected in some
different ways.
And you're just choosing,
is it by album?
Is it by time or location or
other facets such as that?
That works well.
We could use a Navigation
drawer.
And it's an interesting
pattern to think
about in this case.
You could just do the very
basic thing, where you do
those same top level categories,
and you can
present them in the Drawer.
That works.
You could push it a little
further, if you wanted.
You can imagine making those
categories in and of
themselves expandable.
So that, within albums, I could
do my navigating for
which particular album I'd
like to move into.
But I'll caution
you about that.
At this point, you're
translating the way that you
would present that content just
to fit the pattern, where
using Spinners, you would get
thumbnails that represent what
those albums are and what
photos are inside it.
Now, you've just changed the
same albums into text labels.
I think that's probably working
against what you're
trying to achieve in a gallery
app, which is all about
browsing that content
and just getting all
those emotional triggers.
Tabs wouldn't work
all that well.
You have too many things
to pack into the tab.
You have the similar constraints
about the gesture
that we saw on the Calendar,
where I want to pan my photos,
but now I'm panning through
tabs, and now I got to make my
photos go vertically.
And the real estate crunch
is especially bad here.
You're packing in more space.
Now, I have smaller photos.
Now, I'm just not getting that
rich response to it.
It may seem like it's a
small amount of space.
It's only 48 DIPs.
But it makes an impact
in your layout.
And it can have a really
dramatic impact on the
experience that you get when you
look at content like this.
JENS NAGEL: So last up this
Drive, which is Google's file
cloud storage, as most
of you will know.
Drive made an interesting choice
to use the action bar
Spinner for switching
accounts.
So this is totally fine.
And we do this in actually
a couple of apps.
So if you, as a developer, feel
that account switching is
a relatively frequent occurrence
in your app, then
putting it into the action bar
into the Spinner control at
the top level is
actually good.
But that sort of limits our
choices of what we can do
around the top level
switching problem.
And the way that Drive solved
it, they basically exposed the
top level of your file hierarchy
inside of the
content area.
This is not really the top level
of your file hierarchy,
because they are just
static links.
It's not your data.
So essentially, it's a modified
six-pack that we
looked at, at the
very beginning.
We have no access to
actual data here.
It sort of makes this
a meh solution.
It would be nicer if we could
actually do something like
this, where we can get direct
access to the data
as we open the app.
Here, we're using the
modified Spinner.
And we've done that
in the past.
And for example, Gmail uses a
similar mechanism, where one
Spinner actually controls
account selection but also
does top level switching.
It dilutes a little bit what
a Spinner really should be.
Really, a Spinner should
be setting item
with a single focus.
So again, it's not super.
But we're getting closer,
because now we can see data,
which is nice.
What if we used the
Navigation Drawer?
Now, this would, for Drive,
really be an excellent choice,
because now we can, again,
show data immediately.
And the top level navigation and
account selection now can
co-exist in the same Drawer.
And we could even give direct
access to certain folders that
maybe the user has starred and
surfaced as particularly
important to them.
So probably the best
solution for Drive.
We want to, in closing, spend
a little bit of time to talk
about challenges that
particularly developers
encounter as their
apps evolve.
So if you have an app out in the
Play Store, you know that
over the lifespan, you add
a lot of functionality.
You add a lot of new data
and features to it.
And you should always be mindful
of the structural
impact that it actually might
have on your app.
Let's go through a quick
example here.
Imagine you build a really
nice, simple and focused
sports app.
And what it does, it covers
three kinds of sports, because
there are big three US sports at
the time that you were most
interested in.
And you can here, switch
between the sports.
You can see the latest scores.
You tap on the score and see
the detail of the game.
Really simple.
No need for settings, nothing.
Looks great.
This is sort of what the
structure looks like-- three
sports on top, and then they all
point to one screen that
shows the actual game data for
something that you selected at
the top level.
People generally love your app
for its simplicity, but they
also ask for change.
RICHARD FULCHER: Once you launch
the app, you're going
to get feedback from users.
And that's true if you're
collecting it yourself from
within your application.
Maybe you're following some of
the agile research processes
from the prior talk.
Or maybe you're just reading
the always politely-worded
comments or reviews left
on the Play Store.
So you might get things like,
Jens, it's Stanley Cup season.
Where are my hockey stats?
JENS NAGEL: Let's assume if I
was a designer and I listened
to all the feedback, this could
be what my laundry list
looks like of things to do.
So I might want to add hockey
and soccer as new sports.
I want to segment sports that
I already have into college
and pro, because there's a lot
of college fans out there that
asked for that function.
People asked for a place where
they can actually customize
one screen to see their favorite
teams across sports.
There's requests for live score
notification for their
favorite teams, so that they
get a notification on their
phone once a score
actually changes.
And in consequence, we need
a new place where we can
actually set up the
notifications as well as the
favorite teams.
So a first impulse is often to
take all that functionality
and pilot on top of your
existing top level navigation,
because so far, people
actually like
what you've been doing.
And nothing really technically
prevents you from expanding
the tabs up there by
so many options.
It actually works.
And this is actually what you
would be ending up with by
just adding new features to
the app in the existing UI
infrastructure.
And let's see, are we
happy with this?
Let's look at a couple
of problem areas.
First off, if I like NFL
football and soccer, those
screens are now six
swipes apart.
So it's not really that
random [? access-y ?]
anymore.
It's not very speedy
or efficient.
Next problem is glancability.
If I open this for the first
time, what I see is my team's
NFL football and
NCAA football.
Question is, do people discover
that there's more
hiding there?
Because right now, all the
options that we added are not
disclosing themselves.
So people might look at
this and say, well,
I'm a hockey fan.
I don't like football, so
I go to a different app.
We are at least at risk that
people will not discover all
the functionality that
we've added.
Next one is settings.
So we needed to add some
settings in order to manage
our notifications and
my favorite teams.
And compared to the other top
level items, Settings is not
really an important place.
You don't want people to
traverse Settings if they
don't actually want
to go there.
So it really doesn't belong
in the top level.
I should have quick access to
it when I need it, but it
shouldn't be part of my
top level structure.
So the way how we usually solve
that in Android is you
have an action bar
with overflow.
And inside of the overflow
settings, there's an expected
item where users will
look for it.
And that let's me quickly
dive in and out of it.
Wherever I am in the app,
it's always available.
So in putting all those problems
together and in
perspective, a better choice
would probably here, again, be
something like a Navigation
Drawer, where you have
quicker, more efficient
top level navigation.
Your entire content is glancable
once you open it,
because there's a lot of space
for all the different items
that I've added.
It reflects the segmentation
between pro and college sports
nicely by putting it into
this collapsible item.
And its future-proof.
So this item is designed to
hold a lot of different
navigation items.
So as you expand your
application in the future,
it's made for taking all that
new functionality that you
will be adding.
RICHARD FULCHER: So just in
closing, three points.
First, you've got a ton of
different options you
can pick from here.
But they're all suited for
different purposes.
And hopefully, we've
helped teach you a
little bit about that.
You really need to anticipate
how your
application is going to evolve.
Don't design for the V1.
Design for V2, V3, V4.
Be thinking of the long
view when you
decide your app structure.
And then finally, challenge
yourself.
As you leave today, think
about, for the apps that
you've developed, if you've
used one of the different
patterns that we've shown today,
would it be better?
Would it be worse?
Thanks very much for
your time today.
[APPLAUSE]
RICHARD FULCHER: We'll
take questions at the
Office Hours upstairs.
And enjoy the rest
of your I/O.